there comes a time in every man's life
when he's just gotta do another update
video another vlog video well I want to
do a quick one on this game engine that
I introduced a few videos back and just
let you guys kind of know where it's at
and what it's looking like so I've got a
whole bunch of engine classes now can
you even see these maybe am I gonna move
it over so I've got a whole bunch of
engine classes that have begun to handle
most of the windowing the input system
and I've also introduced a new thing I
don't know if other people do this or
not but basically what I have here is an
engine class that when you instantiate
it sort of ties everything together
it needs a keyboard mouse and scroll
wheel setup so it can handle your input
and it has a begin function and update
with Delta time a render function and
update without the also time and also I
have in here something else that I
thought I'd give a try that seems like a
pretty interesting way of doing things
so I want to be able to script this I
want someone else to be able to wrote
write their own object file or source
file that turns into an object file and
basically populate these functions so
what I've got here is a vector of
functions now there might be a better
way of doing this but this is what I'm
trying for now so let me know in the
comments below what you think of this
whole method that I'm setting up here so
basically as a programmer let's say I'll
just show it in one of these I'll be
able to make functions like so auto give
it a name give it a lambda or a function
and then you add it to that part of the
engine
Delta update begin whatever it may be so
once you call the main engine and go to
the main loop which is in the run it
basically just cycles through these it
does the begin once before you want in
the while loop and those are update or
render
your other update and this final update
includes whatever the keys are to you
setup so another thing you have to do
and this is sort of weird let me look at
one of these here is you have to put a
function end that handles the keys and
well the thing I'm worried about is once
you start getting kind of fool or
becoming larger raises it might get slow
so we'll have to see what happens there
and I don't have the OpenGL context yet
it's all partially built and I'm not
really happy with it yet so I don't want
to show it off but I will show you guys
what it looks like right now when you
just run it so I hit I hit the Run
button it looks like it's compiling here
it's make sure it had no build errors
let's see build yeah we're good
succeeded okay so what you get here when
you launch it is you get a window in the
middle of your screen
and now there's still the same as the
last video or basically you can do
whatever you want let me get these so
you can actually read it ok so it
launches now this is just running
through a series of tests so that's all
this code is doing right now it tries to
load a model seems to get all the info
from it so that's good
tries to load a second model that's a
little more random with a lot more
vertices seems to do that ok and then I
try to open a bad file and it gives me
the proper message then it gives me a
hit space to continue so I've got it in
a loop right now or it's waiting for a
space key basically so hit stop and goes
to a pause state which is this red red
screen and it says hit enter to continue
stops again and now I'm going into
another loop so yeah I programmed in
those doing different stuff with windows
so as I as I switch things no this is
the main loop I'm there's so many things
to talk about but I'm just gonna get to
the point here because I don't want to
overdo it and make it even worse if you
guys want to see more consider doing
something to help out my kid in the lake
button or
dare I say go to my patreon and help out
there I've got nothing there so far if
someone gave me a cent I'd be ecstatic
because that is in infinite times more
than anybody has ever donated one cent
so if you want to see more I will spend
more time on these and explain more okay
now we're going to the engine function
test I know
basically this just changes the screen
to random colors so that's just testing
a screen setting function that I put in
a test and my next step basically is to
get this running with some OpenGL
context now the thing about this is it's
really up to the developer maybe the
developer wants to just stay in a flat
2d and doesn't want to use OpenGL and I
want to give that option so I want there
to be quite a bit of versatility in this
whole graphics and game object class so
that's basically what I'm working on
next and focusing on now that the
windowing system seems to be good and
starting to stopping engine seems to be
fine and overall these functions seem to
work I'll have to test more as we get
further and see if there are better ways
of doing it well let me know what you
guys think below thank you so much for
tuning in my name is Matt and I'll see
you guys in the next video peace out
keep code